.
LET ME BRING IN BYRON DONALDS
CONGRESSMAN FROM FLORIDA.
YOU AND I ARE BOTH FLORIDA
RESIDENTS.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PRIMARIES WITH SCHOOL BOARD
ELECTIONS WHERE PARENTS AND
SUBURBAN MOTHERS SHOWED UP IN
DROVES AND BOOTED OUT THE OLD
REGIME.
I THINK THOSE PARENTS AND MOMS
ARE GOING TO SHOW UP AGAIN IN
THIS ELECTION.
>> THEY ARE SHOWING UP, AND IT'S
NOT JUST THEM.
IT'S EVERY OTHER AMERICAN.
IN THIS CASE FLORIDIAN THAT
PISSED OFF WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
TRIED TO DO.
WHEN DeSANTIS OPENED UP OUR
STATE JOE BIDEN WAS AGAINST IT.
IN OTHER STATES THEY EITHER LOST
THE BASE ALL TOGETHER, THEY
WANTED TO LOCK OUT OUR KIDS FROM
THE CLASSROOM.
RON DeSANTIS PUT THEM BACK IN
WHEN YOU LOOK NOW, OUR KIDS ARE
AHEAD OF OTHER KIDS IN THE
COUNTRY.
KEEPING FLORIDA FREE AND KEEPING
FLORIDA RED IS WHAT PROTECTED
THEM FROM THE RADICAL POLICIES
OF THE DEMOCRATS AND JOE BIDEN.
DAN: MIAMI-DADE COUNTY, A
RELATIVELY BLUE COUNTY,
REPUBLICANS HAVE HAD SOME
TROUBLE WITH.
THE JOKE IN FLORIDA, THE MORE
NORTH YOU GO THE MORE SOUTH YOU
GET.
MIAMI-DADE COUNTY, IT APPEARS
THIS COULD BE WON BY RON
DeSANTIS.
I THINK IT'S BECAUSE OF HIS
MANIC AND MINORITY VOTERS
FINALLY GETTING THE TRUTH.
>> ANYBODY WHO HAS BEEN TO
MIAMI-DADE FOR ANY PARTICULAR
PERIOD OF TIME.
IT'S MASSIVELY A HISPANIC LATINO
COUNTY.
SO FOR IT TO BE CLOSE THE WAY IT
IS NOW AND EVEN HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO GO RED LIKE SOME
PEOPLE ARE THINKING DEMOCRATS
THE POINT YOU MAKE.
PEOPLE OF LATIN DESCENT, THEY
HAVE SEEN THE LEADERSHIP FROM
RON DeSANTIS AND THEY ARE
CHOOSING THAT OVER THE LIES AND
POLICIES OF THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
I KIND OF FEEL BAD FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, BUT NOT TOO MUCH
BECAUSE IT'S THEIR OWN FALL.
THEY CHOSE TO GO DOWN THE LITANY
OF B